menozzi maze et messieurs bonjour
comment vous allez j'espère que tout se
passe bien pour vous j'espère vous allez
bien que la vie est belle que les
oiseaux chantent que voilà ça va voilà
j'espère que ça va et ça c'est hyper
important alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
on va parler de sujets très importants a
parlé de cette erreur de 7,7 comme ça
faisait même plus court désormais doit 5
et de 7 voilà c'est comme ça
cette erreur qu'ils font ramé votre
smartphone et surtout je vais vous dire
comment venir corriger ces problèmes
comment les solutionner pour que vous
n'ayez plus enfin de problèmes qu'ils
fassent rien et passe partout parce que
ça ça c'est vraiment pénible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elles sont juste là elles sont sous nos
yeux c'est cette erreur je vais vous les
énumérer vous allez voir c'est pas très
très compliqué mais c'est vrai que au
final 11 ya cessé à ça fait râler si
j'avais su je l'aurais pas fait j'aurais
fait les choses différemment ses astuces
elle marche aussi bien sur un android
que sur un os dans les deux cas on est
tranquilles ils ont quel que soit votre
smartphone vous allez pouvoir venir
corriger ces problèmes pour ne plus les
abords et ne plus avoir à les subir
d'ailleurs dit moi dès maintenant vous
tout de suite avant qu'on commence
est ce que votre smartphone rama est ce
qu'il ya des causes particulières que
vous avez identifié qui fait que ça ne
va pas ça ne conviendrait pas
qu'est-ce qui fait ramer votre
smartphone je vous énumère sept points
qui me paraissent être les points
essentiels les points principaux
les points bloquants qu'on va tous
rencontrer un moment ou un autre dans
notre vie de smartphones east va comme
on dit en tout cas on les a tous ces
problèmes moi je les ai connus j'en ai
connu certains le premier point et je
les ai eus c'est d'acheter un smartphone
avec trop peu de stockage
quand on va acheter un smartphone en
règle générale la première chose qu'on
va regarder c'est le budget le budget le
budget le budget on achète un smartphone
en fonction de ses moyens et c'est
normal et quand on a le choix entre une
configuration 64 géant du stockage 128
256 ou même carrément 512 on se rend
compte qu'à un moment et bien en termes
de budget entre 64 et 128 ou 64 à 256 à
512 ne parlons même pas ça fait vraiment
fortement augmenté l'addition et arrive
un moment où on se dit je vais peut-être
prendre en beauce mart phone mais
prendre un peu moins de stockage parce
que forcément ça va coûter une fortune
et la fortune je veux pas l'âne est là
donc ils arrivent après quelques mois
d'utilisation et bien qui est un peu un
embouteillage sur l'autoroute des
données de votre smartphone et que ça ne
passe plus ça ne fonctionne plus parce
que votre smartphone a trop peu de
stockage
ça c'est un point que j'avais rencontré
qu'un smartphone où j'avais je crois 16
giga de stockage j'ai bloqué 16 giga je
devais supprimer deux applications pour
henri installer une c'était une vraie
galère cette année avec un ancien iphone
savent ce que je vous conseille de faire
votre smartphone il est ce qu'il est a
de toute façon vous n'allez pas le
changer tout de suite pour avoir plus de
stockage vous verrez sur l'achat de
votre prochain smartphone mais pour
l'instant vous restez comme vous êtes ce
qu'il faut faire c'est déjà si vous avez
un smartphone android et vous avez un
lecteur de cartes sd et bien vous mettez
une carte sd vous monté jusqu'à 1 tera
des fois même jusqu'à de terrain ça
dépend de votre smartphone bien certain
qu'il accepte et là vous stockez un max
de choses dans votre carte sd d'une
carte micro sd vous permettra
effectivement de venir libérer de la
place sur vos smartphones si maintenant
vous n'avez pas de lecteur de cartes
microsd ou si le lecteur de cartes
microsd et pleins ou quelqu'un a vécu
quand même un peu ballot eh bien il faut
bien stockées dans le cloud
moi je le fais je le fais tout le temps
je stocke mes photos dans le cloud je
stocke mes vidéos et je décharge tout ce
que j'ai dans mon smartphone pour être
tranquille il ya un autre point qui est
aussi important et auquel on pense pas
assez aujourd'hui quand on offre une
belle photo on en fait deux trois quatre
à la suite pour avoir vraiment la belle
image est souvent on ne supprime pas les
trois photos les deux photos qui ne
serviront strictement rien qu'on
n'utilisera jamais donc penser à venir
supprimer tous ces doublons et
d'ailleurs il ya des applications qui
vous permettent de le faire notamment
dans google photo vania vous proposer un
moment de supprimer les doublons donc
supprimer ces doublons supprimer les
vidéos qui pèse très lourd que vous
n'utilisez pas et vous l'utiliserez plus
jamais si par exemple mettre vos story
directement une votre application de
photos et qu'ensuite vous l'importez
dans votre instagram
il ya supprimer les vidéos que vous avez
enregistré votre n'aurait normalement
plus besoin donc vous mettez toutes ces
petites astuces boutabout et vous allez
voir vous allez gagner de la place dans
votre smartphone la deuxième erreur
qu'on fait tous
elle vous rappellera probablement la
première c'est à dire le fait d'abord
installé trop d'applications et il ya un
embouteillage on a plus de place alors
c'est pas forcément vous allez être
limité parce que si vous avez par
exemple 128g le stockage vous avez mis
tellement de jeux vous avez mis
tellement de musique tellement de vidéos
non ya plus de place ce que je vous
conseille c'est devenir supprimer les
applications que vous n'utilisez plus
souvent gardé assez par ailleurs sur mon
téléphone j'ai des pages et des pages et
des pages et des pages d'applications
que je n'utilise pas que je ne dirais
probablement jamais ou que j'ai utilisé
une fois que j'ai trouvé sympa mais que
j'ai pas supprimée alors ici j'ai
beaucoup de stockage 1 512 donc je peux
remettre un petit peu
mais ça me sert globalement à rien donc
si vous voyez vous commencé à arriver à
une limite à une saturation vous
supprimez les applications quitte à les
réinstaller plus tard d'ailleurs il
existe notamment sur android des
applications en ait un facebook lite par
exemple qui pèsera moins lourd et vous
pouvez venir installer très facilement
j'ai une autre erreur qu'on fait souvent
et à laquelle on ne pense pas c'est
venir vider le cache de son smartphone
parce que oui avoir un bon smartphone
c'est super à voir pleins d'applications
c'est super mais ses applications au fur
et à mesure du temps elles vont venir se
remplir se remplir de date à se remplir
d'information et arrive un moment où ces
applications il pèse très lourd c'est la
tap est très lourde et vous n'en avez
globalement pas besoin ce que je vous
conseille de faire c'est de venir vider
votre cash regarder je vous montre ici
dans un iphone vous faites la même chose
sur android ça marche très très bien des
applications qui vous permettront de le
faire vous venez ici dans votre iphone
vous allez dans général vous allez
ensuite dans stockage iphone et à vous
voyez tous veulent stockage je vois que
j'ai les applications inutilisées je
peux économiser 16,80 2 gigas de
stockage je peux donc venir décharger
ici des applications que je n'utilise
pas c'est assez énorme et c'est pareil
sur les anciennes conversation regarder
je peux supprimer 400 un méga bon c'est
un petit peu moins mais quand même alors
c'est pareil moi par exemple sur spotify
je télécharge de la musique directement
dans mon spotify donc je peux me dire
les supprimer pour économiser ce qu'il
faut faire c'est cliquez ici sur des
charges et l'apsa va venir vider tout le
contenu en cash
qu'est-ce que j'ai qui me prend un peu
de place à imovie ou j'ai tous mes vieux
fichiers de denjean n'est pas forcément
besoin regarder à imovie j'ai un giga 72
taille des documents 1 giga a fait des
charges et la pop là je valide ici
symbole in st mouline symbole in ça
mouline
bon ce n'est un peu de temps à mouliner
ça mouline et moi finir par y arriver
hélas alors là je les plus à imovie et
ça m'a vidé mon contenu donc ça c'est un
truc tout bête mais qu'il faut vraiment
venir prendre en compte venez ici des
charges et vos applications venait vider
votre cash que ce soit sur un os que ce
soit sur android comme ça vous serez
peinard quatrième erreur qu'on est très
nombreux à faire c'est télécharger
installer des jeux qui sont trop
gourmand pour votre smartphone
si vous me prenez un force nay dans la
foule configuration et vous voulez faire
tourner sur un smartphone à 200 euros il
ya un moment ça risque de bloquer un
petit peu il faut venir installer des
jeux qui correspondent à votre
smartphone alors souvent on n'y connaît
pas grand chose on achète un snapdragon
numéro quelque chose on n'y comprend
rien et là on se fait un peu avoir parce
qu'on se dit ok j'ai acheté un super
smartphone pour le gaming qui marche
bien pour le
ming sur youtube sur les tests j'ai vu
que ça ira pour le gaming oui ca pour le
gaming mais pas pour tous les jeux il ya
des jeux qui tournent rond de ce fait de
jeu qu'ils ne tourneront pas donc penser
vraiment regarder dans les commentaires
des vidéos poser les questions est ce
que ça peut fonctionner est ce que ça
marchera ou pas pour ne pas déchanter
parce qu il se peut même que vous
réussissiez à installer des jeux
gourmands sera smartphones qui
globalement ne peut pas le faire tourner
ça fonctionne mais sarah ben ça rame
tellement que l'expérience de jeu elle
n'est plus là c'est pas sympa c'est pas
agréable
c'est juste parce que le jeu ne marche
pas avec votre processeur et dans tous
les cas ça ne marchera pas ça c'est
ballot la cinquième erreur je les fais
je l'ait expérimentée
c'est d'installer une mise à jour qui
fait ramer votre machine alors je les
fais sur une tablette sur un ipad
il ya quelques années j'ai installé la
énième mise à jour s'était pas encore
ipad ou est en tout cas j'avais installé
dernière mise à jour de l'os et ça n'a
fait ramer mais tellement ram et la
machine que je l'ait vraiment regretter
j'avais même essayé de contacter apple
pour leur dire comment je pars pour
revenir en arrière j'ai pas de solution
je ne peux pas revenir en arrière est ce
qu'il existe une astuce pour revenir à
la version d'avant ils m'ont dit c'est
strictement impossible
la version que vous avez installé vous
la gardez on ne peut pas revenir en
arrière il m'a même conseillé de faire
encore une mise à jour pour sarah -
globalement arrive un moment où vos
machines il faut plus leur faire mise à
jour si vous êtes à je sais pas je donne
un chiffre un petit peu au hasard mais
votre machine elle a deux ans vous
voulez qu'on vous propose une énième
mise à jour que votre machine est
compatible pour cette énième mise à jour
ne le fait pas forcément au bout de deux
ans arrêté à moins que ce vraiment une
mise à jour de sécurité critique il
fallait vraiment faire sinon arrêter
parce que vous allez avoir de nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui vont venir consommer
davantage et même si votre machine est
compatible
il se peut que ça marche pas ça ne
fonctionne pas vraiment il faut savoir
s'arrêter au bout de deux ans et c'est
pas une question de sécurité vraiment
critique critique critique
n'y allez pas arrêtez vous ce qui nous
amène maintenant à notre sixième erreur
et bien c'est ne pas faire mise à jour a
alors là ce seront je comprends rien il
me dit qu'il faut pas faire les mises à
jour et demi qui veut faire les mises à
jour c'est il faut faire les mises à
jour je dis juste qui arrive un moment
où il faut plus faire mise à jour mais à
contrario si vous ne faites pas les
mises à jour qu'il faut faire acquis
sont préconisées eh bien vous risquez
d'avoir une machine qui plan parce qu'il
se peut sur la version actuelle de votre
os il y un bug a corrigé qui va venir
améliorer la performance de la machine
donc pensé à faire les mises à jour
jusqu'à deux ans j'achète une machine
par exemple aujourd'hui en 2020 tiens je
vais venir faire les mises à jour
jusqu'en 2023 et en 2023 je ne ferai
plus mise à jour sauf si vraiment des
mises à jour de sécurité critiques ou
des mises à jour comme sur android des
mises
jour de sécurité que l'âge de venir
faire et si je peux venir choisir de
mise à jour c'est encore b donc on les
fait jusqu'à ce qu'on les fasse plus et
puis la dernière astuce la 7e
c'est ce que je conseille toujours à
quelqu'un qui m'appelle qui m'envoie un
message qui me dit monsieur brun
monsieur greu sahara mais j'en peux plus
j'ai ce problème
je ne peux plus imprimer à partir de ça
ça ne veut plus partir ça ne fonctionne
pas et ça je vous le dis que ce soit
pour un smartphone pour une tablette
pour un pc pour tout matériel
électronique
la première chose à faire est l'erreur
qu'on ne sait tous c'est qu'on ne le
redémarre pas vous prenez votre pc vous
l'éteignez vous le rallumer ils vont
râler si ça marche aussi ça marche pas
la même chose avec nos smartphones
aujourd'hui on a pris l'habitude d'avoir
des machines tellement réactive on veut
tellement que ce soit instantanée et
rapide qu'on ne le démarque plus ces
machines et qu'on ne comprend pas qu'on
n'accepte pas qu'un moment ça rame et
que ça ne fonctionne plus c'est simple
votre machine à moment elle travaille
elle travaille elle travaille à un
moment elle travaille plus ça bloque
elle est saturée ça ne fonctionne plus
elle ne veut plus j'ai eu le cas à
l'autre jour dans ma famille on le dit
aurait bien l'imprimante ne marche plus
je dis d'accord
qu'est ce qui se passe mon tel message
effectivement c'est incohérent
tu est un ordinateur tu l'a rallumé tu
as tenté à nouveau nom allez on y va on
fait ça est un on a rallumé on a lancé
l'impression tout allait bien c'est
vraiment un truc tout bête mais c'est la
première chose à faire quand vous avez
un plantage ne cherchait pas à appeler
pierpoljak un ennemi ou compagnie
éteignez redémarrer réessayer et là si
ça ne marche pas aussi d'aller un peu
plus loin
voilà pour cette astuce alors un petit
dernier bonus qui est important c'est on
se dit souvent
ah ben tiens j'ai pleins d'applications
qui sont ouvertes en même temps c'est
hyper en béton regardez j'ai toutes mes
apps qui sont là est-ce que ça fait
ramener ma machine est ce qu'il faut que
les états unis tout est bien souvent
beaucoup de personnes vont venir
éteindre fermées en tout cas une par une
toutes les applications
ça ne sert à rien aujourd'hui ses
applications en tâche de fond sont très
bien gérés que ce soit sur un os que ce
soit sur android ça marche très bien
c'est très bien géré ça ne consomme pas
ce n'est pas du tout énergivores donc
c'est pas ça qui va venir faire ramer
votre machine
soyez tranquilles et soyez rassurés là
dessus à moins que vous ayez une version
d'android 5 auquel cas on peut en
reparler mais sur toutes les versions
actuelles des smartphones récents vous
n'aurai absolument aucun problème
dites moi vous à votre tour est-ce que
vous avez une astuce a rajouté une
erreur que vous connaissez qu'on fait
tous et qui nous fait ramer notre
machine marqué le mois bien évidemment
en bas en commentait casque avait une
erreur que j'ai citées dans cette liste
la queue
vous faites vous régulièrement et que
maintenant vous connaissez et vous
n'allez plus faire marquer moi tout ça
bien évidemment en bas en commentaire et
dites moi si vous voulez qu'on fasse
d'autres vidéos ce genre est ce qu a des
idées de vidéos marque elle et moi bien
évidemment tout ça en bas sur ce je vous
embrasse nous embrasse très fort très
fort dans le micro je vous parle dans la
touffe là pour parler dans le micro
je vous embrasse prenez soin de vous des
gros bisous de l'amour et à très vite
ciao ciao